>> Kennedy: VERY GOOD.
AS THE SIMPLY CRISIS GETS WORSE
AND RAMPANT INFLATION SMACKS THE
CONSUMER IN THE CASE AND NOBODY
LOOKS FOR THE COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF
FOR ANSWERS.
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAYS HE DOESN'T
HAVE A CLUE ON HOW TO FIX ANY OF
THOSE PROBLEMS.
WATCH.
>> I DON'T HAVE A NEAR-TERM
ANSWER.
THERE'S TWO THINGS THAT I COULD
DO.
I CAN GO IN THE PETROLEUM
RESERVE AND TAKE OUT AND
PROBABLY RELEASE -- REDUCE THE
PRICE OF GAS MAYBE 18 CENTS OR
SO A GALLON.
STILL GOING TO BE ABOVE $3.
LONG SHOREMEN DON'T ALWAYS GET
ALONG WITH THE BUSINESS FOLKS
THERE.
I HAVE A RELATIONSHIP WITH THEM.
I BROUGHT THEM TOGETHER AND I
SAID YOU HAVE TO BE OPEN 24/7.
NO PORT THERE WAS OPEN FIVE DAY
AS WEEK, 40 HOURS A WEEK.
24/7.
THEY HAVE ALWAYS AGREED TO IT.
NEY HAVE AGREED TO IT.
>> Kennedy: I FEEL LIKE HE'S
REALLY TRYING TO BLAME THE LONG
SHOREMEN NOW, JESSE.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT IS THE BEST
MOVE FOR HIM.
THIS WAS OBVIOUSLY A GREAT
SHOWING BY THE PRESIDENT.
>> Jesse: TREMENDOUS
PERFORMANCE.
>> Kennedy: HE HAD ANSWERS FOR
EVERYTHING, ESPECIALLY SUPPLY
CHAIN.
>> Jesse: HE DOES HAVEN'T ANY
ANSWERS.
HUNTER HANDLES HIS FINANCES.
IN A RECOVERY, YOU HAVE TO HAVE
SUPPLY MEET COMMAND.
YOU CAN'T TAKE AWAY PERMITS AND
PIPELINES AND LEASES.
SO RIGHT NOW WE'RE BEGGING OPEC
TO INCREASE SUPPLY.
OPEC SAYS SCREW YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE IT GO TO $100
A BARREL AND WE'RE GOING TO GET
RICH AND JOE CAN GO SCRATCH.
HE DOESN'T HAVE ANY ANSWERS.
HE CAMPAIGNED ON THIS.
HE SAID WE'RE TOING TO GET RID
OF FOSSIL FUELS.
HERE'S THE REAL PROBLEM.
AS THE INFLATION GOES UP, GAS
PRICES AND OIL GOES UP.
AND A WEAKER DOLLAR MAKES GAS
PRICES AND OIL GO EVEN FURTHER
UP.
SO HE'S GOING TO HAVE HIGH
PRICES, HIGH INFLATION AND A
WEAK DOLLAR AND SIT AROUND AND
HAVE NO ANSWERS FOR THIS.
I DON'T THINK HE HAS A CLUE WHAT
TO DO AND IT'S CLEAR.
>> Kennedy: A LOT OF THESE
THINGS TO PEOPLE, THEY DON'T
REALLY UNDERSTAND OR WANT TO
INVESTIGATE WHAT TRANSITORY
INFLATION IS.
BUT THEY KNOW WHAT HIGH GAS
PRICES ARE.
THEY KNOW THAT THAT BITES THEM
IN THE KEISTER.
I DON'T CARE IF IT'S JOE BIDEN
WHO IS THE PRESIDENT OR
PRESIDENT TRUMP OR PRESIDENT
OBAMA OR JIMMY CARTER.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE AN ANSWER FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE HURTING
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE'RE GETTING
INTO THE HOLIDAYS.
EVERYTHING IS MORE EXPENSIVE.
GAS IS RIDICULOUS.
HE WAS LIKE I DON'T REALLY HAVE
AN ANSWER IN THE NEAR TERM.
>> Jessica: GAS PRICES AND EMPTY
SHELVES.
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THAT.
NOT DURING THE HEIGHT OF A
PANDEMIC, IN THE MIDST OF
WHATEVER THIS NEW NORMAL IS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE LIVING THROUGH
IN PERPETUITY.
I'VE BEEN TALKING TO PAST FEW
WEEKS ON THE SHOW ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE PRESIDENT AT
LEAST OWNING WHAT'S GOING ON.
I THINK THAT WAS AN IMPORTANT
ELEMENT OF THIS.
THAT THERE WAS -- IT WAS HIM
TALKING TO A JOURNALIST, PEOPLE
WANTED HIM TO GET INTERVIEWED.
HE GOT INTERVIEWED.
QUESTIONS FROM THE AUDIENCE.
I DON'T THINK THIS ANSWER WAS
SUFFICIENT FOR PEOPLE BECAUSE
THEY'RE STILL GOING TO BE
SAYING, WELL HOW CAN YOU -- YOU
SAID INFLATION WOULD BE A NEAR
TERM PROBLEM.
RON KLAIN SAID THAT.
THAT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE IT'S THE
CASE.
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO?
ONE THING THAT I THOUGHT WAS
GREAT THOUGH IN THAT HE
EXPLAINED THE MECHANICS OF
GETTING A BILL PASSED.
HE TALKED ABOUT HOW HE DOESN'T
HAVE THE VOTES TO GET THE
FILIBUSTER REFORM.
THERE WERE THREE HOLDOUTS.
WE THINK IT'S JOE MANCHIN HAND
KYRSTEN SINEMA.
KYRSTEN.
>> Kennedy: THEY'RE BOTH
>> Jessica: SO I THOUGHT THAT
WAS INTERESTING.
BUT THAT ANSWER WON'T SATISFY
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE BUT I
APPRECIATE THAT HE TOOK THE
QUESTION BECAUSE THEY WERE
WAITING.
>> Jesse: HE TOOK IT FROM A
STACKED AUDIENCE.
THOSE WERE HAND PICKED PEOPLE.
THREE DEMOCRATS --
>> Jessica: THEY WEREN'T ALWAYS
DEMOCRATS.
>> Kennedy: TWO INDEPENDENTS.
VERY FEW REPUBLICANS.
>> Jessica: TWO REPUBLICANS.
>> Jesse: YOU KNOW IT AND I KNOW
IT.
>> Kennedy: AND THEY WERE AT THE
VERY END WHEN NOBODY IS WATCHING
ANYMORE.
THE PRESIDENT HAD SOMETHING
INTERESTING TO SAY IN TERMS OF
VACCINES AND FREEDOM.
WATCH THIS.
>> SHOULD POLICE OFFICERS,
EMERGENCY RESPONDERS BE MANDATED
TO GET VACCINES AND IF NOT,
SHOULD THEY STAY AT HOME OR LET
GO?
>> YES AND YES.
THE TWO THINGS THAT CONCERN ME,
ONE ARE THOSE THAT JUST TRY TO
MAKE THIS A POLITICAL ISSUE.
FREEDOM.
I HAVE THE FREEDOM TO KILL YOU
WITH MY COVID.
NO, COME ON.
FREEDOM.
>> Kennedy: YEAH.
COME ON, FREEDOM.
IT'S A GREAT THING.
HE HAS IT WRONG HERE, DAGEN?
>> Dagen: WHAT A UNIFIER.
WHAT A WARM PERSON WHO IS REALLY
BRINGING THE COUNTRY TOGETHER.
HE'S CLEARLY TRAPPED IN A BUBBLE
SURROUNDED BY SOCIALISTS.
BECAUSE HE'S STILL STICKING TO
THE DIRTY UNWASHED TRUMP VOTER
IS THE ONE THAT IS UNVACCINATED.
CAN WE GET KYRIE IRVING ON THE
HORN TO MAKE SURE IT'S NOT AN
ISSUE OF RACE OR POLITICAL
PERSUASION, NUMBER 1.
NUMBER 2, DOES HE KNOW THAT
PEOPLE THAT ARE VACCINATED CAN
GET COVID?
ARE THEY A DANGER AS WELL TO THE
REST OF US?
AGAIN, IT'S JUST DIVISIVE
UNNECESSARILY.
ONE THING THAT DOES UNITE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE IS LISTENING TO
THIS PERSON STAND UP THERE
INCOHERENT, TALKING OUT OF HIS
ASS ABOUT THESH THAT NATURAL
GUARD HELPING OUT TRUCKERS WHICH
THE WHITE HOUSE HAD TO BACKTRACK
OR TELLING THE GOD AWFUL
AMERICAN TRUTH TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THE HIGH GAS PRICES ARE DESIGN.
IT'S TO PUSH ELECTRIC VEHICLES.
THIS IS -- DAY ONE, THEY KILLED
THE KEYSTONE PIPELINE AND A
MORATORIUM ON NEW DRILLING.
YOU HAVE THE FEDERAL RESERVE AND
OTHER AGENCIES STRONG ARMING
FINANCIAL FIRMS TO NOT INVEST IN
ENERGY PROJECTS.
I COULD GO ON.
I WON'T.
THIS IS NOT A BUG IN THE SYSTEM.
THIS IS THE FEATURE.
>> Kennedy: ABSOLUTELY.
ONE OF THE FEATURES IS THE WAY
THAT JOE BIDEN JUST STOOD THERE
WITH TWO FISTS.
I KNOW YOU WENT TO MEDICAL
SCHOOL.
>> Greg: YEAH.
THAT'S CALLED THE CORN HOLEO.
IT'S A DISORDER THAT YOU GET
FROM WATCHING BEAVIS AND
BUTTHEAD DURING THE 90s.
THIS CALLS FOR A HALLOWEEN
ANALOGY.
THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE HAS BECOME
THE HOME THAT FOR GOT TO BUY
HALLOWEEN CANDY.
SO THEY'RE TURNING OUT THE
LIGHTS AND PRETENDING THEY'RE
NOT THERE, RIGHT?
MAYOR PETE IS UNDER THE BED.
KAMALA IS IN THE CLOSET.
HE'S TALKING TO A BUSH.
THERE'S NO HEAD ON THIS
HORSEMAN.
THE ONLY THING I CAN THINK OF,
HE -- MAYBE HE HASN'T REALIZED
THIS.
WE REALIZED THIS.
THE WOKE LEFT CONTINGENT
CONTROLLING HIM HAS NO SOLUTION
IN A TIME OF CRISIS.
DIVERSITY TRAINING, PRACTICE
NOUNS, RACIAL POLITICS.
YOU CAN DAB UNTIL THAT STUFF
WHEN TIMES ARE GREAT.
WHEN TIMES ARE NOT GREAT, THEY
SUCK.
JOE JUST ASSUMED THAT SOMEONE
WOULD TAKE CARE OF THESE THINGS.
THERE'S NO ONE IN HIS GROUP.
YOU ACTUALLY DO NEED MODERATE
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS TO
HELP YOU OUT.
WITHOUT THEM, YOU CAN'T
REQUIRE -- YOU CAN'T EXPECT
WOKESTERS TO OPERATE HEAVY
MACHINERY.
THERE'S NOTHING IN THE PLAYBOOK
AND INFLATION OR TAX RATES OR
SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES.
RIGHT?
IT'S ONLY ABOUT RIDICULE AND
RACE.
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE.
AMERICA IS ON AUTO PILOT.
RIGHT?
DOESN'T IT FEEL THAT WAY?
>> Jesse: IT DOES.
>> Greg: THERE'S NO HEAD ON IT.
WE'RE THE GOVERNMENT.
AMERICA IS THE GOVERNMENT.
WE CAN DO WHATEVER WE WANT NOW.
IF EVERYBODY SAYS SCREW THIS,
WE'RE NOT GOING TO DO THE
MANDATES, IT COULD HAPPEN.
>> Jesse: WE CAN DO WHOEVER WE
WANT.
>> Greg: IT'S TIME FOR THE
PURGE, JESSE.
>> Kennedy: THEY DON'T HAVE AN
ANSWER TO ONE